The painters algorithm works by drawing each object fully, in back to front
order. It depends on there not being any cycles where one object is in front of
another, which is front of a third, which in turn is in front of the first.
This image has a red ring that is front of the green. The green is front of the
blue and the blue is in front of the red. Given this cycle it certainly cannot
be rendered with painters algorithm if each ring is drawn as a whole. It's
possible to process the scene and break the objects into pieces that could be
drawn in the proper order but the basic Painter's algorithm clearly fails here.
So this is the answer. By the way, these are called Borromean rings. No two
rings are linked to each other, but still all three are attached.